We're told to graph the
inequality y is less
than 3x plus 5.
So you give me any x, y is going
to be less than 3 times
that x plus 5.
So the way to think about it is
you want to think about the
line y equals 3x plus 5, but
since we're going to be less
than that, instead of drawing
the line, we're going to draw
it as a dotted line and then
shade all the y's that are
less than that.
So let me show you
what I mean.
So if we wanted to just draw 3x
plus 5, if this was just an
equality, if we wanted to draw
that graph-- I'll do it in
this dark green color-- we'd say
OK, the y-intercept here
is positive 5.
So we'd go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And we'd say the slope is 3,
which means if we move 1 in
the x direction, we move up 3.
If we move back in the x
direction, we're going
to move down 3.
If we move back 2, we're
going to go down 6.
2, 4, 6, just like that.
Now, if this was graphing the
line y is equal to 3x plus 5,
we would just connect
all of these dots.
But because we're not less than
or equal to, we're just
less than, we're going to do a
dotted line here to show that
the line is actually not
going to be included.
So let me draw a dotted line
here, which is actually
surprisingly easier to draw
than a regular line.
So that is a dotted line.
We're not going to include
that line, we're going to
include all the y's that are
less than 3x plus 5.
So let's think about
it for second.
If you give me some arbitrary
x, so let's say that x is 0.
If x is 0, then what's
3x plus 5?
Well, 3 times 0 plus 5 is 5.
So y is going to be
less than that.
If x is 0, y has to
be less than 5.
So y is going to be all of
these values down here.
And it would not include-- and
if you were doing it as a
number line, you would do a
circle over there-- you would
not include 5.
If x was equal to 1,
what is 3x plus 5?
3 times 1 is 3, plus 5 is 8.
So y would have to be less
than 8, 8 is over here.
So it's all the values less
than eight over here.
So in general, for any x over
here, the y's that are less
than 3x plus five are
all of the values
below the dotted line.
All of these values below the
dotted line is the graph of
the inequality y is less
than 3x plus 5.
If it was less than or equal
to, you would make that a
solid line.
But it's not, so it's just all
of this area down here.
All of this area below this
line, that's what that less
than tells you.